- So, we came across this video
of Cynthia singing on the street.
So, let's see it and hear it.
(Cynthia laughing)
♪ I'll march my band out ♪
♪ I'll beat my drum ♪
♪ And if I'm fanned out ♪
(audience cheering)
- That was so good.
"Funny Girl", obviously.
- Yeah.
- I love "Funny Girl".
So, that's eight years.
Yeah, I love that whole musical.
But what happened there?
How did you just start singing that?
I love you.
- Well, um, he (laughs).
- You're just like, "You know
what I think I feel like?"
- We're in the middle of the street.
I bumped into him in
the middle of the street
and he asked me to sing something.
I think he must have heard
me sing it one time before.
And he was like, "Can you
just do a little bit of it?
Can you just?
So, I was like, "Okay, sure."
I don't mind any opportunity
where I can make some music.
That's what I'm gonna do.
- Oh, I don't, yeah.
People always,
it's like people coming
up to me and being like,
"Oh, I don't know
if you want me to talk
about "American Idol".
I'm like, "Hell, yeah, dude.
That's like, why I'm here."
Yeah.
- It's also like, there's just, you know-
- You're gonna care when
they don't want you to sing.
- That's the thing.
It's like, I think the
wonderful thing about that.
I knew it would bring him such joy.
And he's such a joyous
energy and I wanted-
- And you made his day.
- It was so awesome and
I was having a great time
and people across the street could see it.
Like, it was just fun.
- And you're reminded, right, of like-
- Why you do it
in the first place.
- Why you do it.
How you fell in love with it.
- Those are important moments.